(orchestral music)
- I know it smells like ass.
- That's about all I know about them
is that they smell really bad.
(orchestral music)
- Yeah, it's like your freezer
when you don't clean it out.
- It seems pretty harmless right now.
I'm not sure what all the
hullaballoo is all about.
(orchestral music)
- (screams) Is it soft?
- I feel like this is how we're gonna die,
like an alien's gonna pop out.
- It's like... Ah, f***!
(carving sounds, grunting)
(knife hitting table)
- (sniffing)
- Does it smell?
- Do you smell that?
- I can start to smell it.
- Oh no!
- Oh s***!
- It's not bad, it kind
of smells like a melon.
- Oh, it smells like farts now!
- Oh.
- Oh my God.
- It just smells like wet garbage.
- Trash, old eggs, cantaloupe,
passion fruit, old refrigerator.
- Oh s***.
- Oh f***.
- Ew
- It's like we opened like
a dead chicken or something.
- This looks like
mayonnaise and body parts.
- It looks kind of pus-sy.
- Why'd you have to say that?
- (laughs)
- So I don't know what part
you're supposed to eat.
- Ew!
- I actually don't think that I'm
going to be able to eat this.
- One, two, three.
- (gagging)
- I like it.
Tastes like a banana and a pineapple.
- Melon with the texture
of an uncooked egg.
- Ah!
- It actually tastes pretty good.
- You don't like it?
- It tastes f***ing terrible!
- Oh, I just got a weird one.
- Definitely not worth the work.
- It's kind of mean to you
when you're trying to eat it.
- It does smell good,
but then you get like
a whiff and it doesn't smell good.
- (gagging)
- And then like, parts of
it does taste ok, but then
you get a bite that's like not ok.
- You can wear a nose plug and
have a good time with some durian.
- It's like a box of
chocolates, but a bad box of
chocolates. You don't know
what you're gonna get.
(laughing)
- What's wrong?
- Just listen.
- (cringing)
- It's so weird!